hey everybody welcome back to css3 in 30
days today is day 16 and we are going to
be making a modal window in only css3 a
modal window is that pop-up window that
you see on websites to subscribe to
something or to give you a notification
an alert of some sort it it's commonly
used in bootstrap and other frameworks
like that it's just a modal window it
pops up in front of your screen to to
alert you of something or request
something of you typically it's built in
JavaScript or jQuery or the like which
requires you to learn those languages or
download a plug-in or learn a specific
framework which is not a big deal but
this course is about making things only
in css3 pushing the boundaries of css3
or at least pushing your boundaries of
what you think css3 can do and in this
case we're going to just make a modal
window only in css3 now what's the
benefit of that well you don't have to
do it in JavaScript or jQuery or
anything like that you don't have to add
that extra step but also this means that
if the person viewing your website or
your application does not have
JavaScript activated or installed or
whatever on their browser and sometimes
that's the case then it still will
appear because it's only CSS so that's
pretty neat let's jump in and let me
show you what that looks like here's the
sixteen CSS only modal window we have
the sandbox with our content here which
will turn into the modal window as you
could see the close button and such but
down here in the final result you can
see if we click to launch modal it will
pop up just like so nice little
animation a little background overlay
the body content to some text and then a
close button which also closes the modal
window so let's jump into our code
editor download 16 modal window give you
a moment to do that pause the video come
back here when you're ready
check out the index file there's a few
things that I want to note here and
explain because the markup is very
important in this lesson we're not going
to be coding the markup but you need to
understand how it works because it's
crucial in how the CSS functions in this
case so let's scroll down here and I
will show you we have
input the first thing you see her under
the H for an input and that input is a
checkbox with the idea of click but the
style is display:none so this input
makes everything happen so we're gonna
hide this input because we don't need to
see it but the state of the input
whether it is checked or unchecked is
what's going to determine if our modal
window appears or not the label here
wraps an a tag which is a button but the
label it has the attribute of for click
which is tying into this input right
here so when we click on this label so
when we click on the button and we're
actually clicking the label because
that's the parent it's going to activate
or check slash uncheck it will toggle
this checkbox now if I if I you know
remove this let me just show you remove
this style you'll see a checkbox and if
I click this it's going to check and
uncheck it and also this down here is
going to do the same and that is very
important so I'm going to style
display:none so down here we have the
div with the ID error class of modal and
just another day with the content and
some markup that's just for styling
purposes but another functionality
element here is the label for click that
is that ID of click up here that
checkbox and then again just a button
with the class of clothes that toggles
that input as well and then down below
that as a sibling of the modal element
we have the day of with the class of
overlay and that will be that black
overlay that we use and really that is
it so when you click on the label for ID
right here we click on this button it's
going to toggle this input when you
click on the close button it will also
toggle the input in CSS we can check to
see if a an input a checkbox is checked
or otherwise which means we can style
based on that attributes being checked
or not so jump into your final dot CSS
if you want to refer to these Styles you
always can as in every lecture every
lesson we have a final does CSS file
where you can go through and see
only differences in the final files it's
going to be prepended with final double
underscore and then the class and that's
simply because the the Styles the final
styles under the final result are on the
same page as the sandbox and I don't
want to have conflicting styles and have
when I style one thing style everything
so I have a separate class or ID for
each of the elements but the difference
is the final elements the final results
start with final double underscore so
that's what you'll see in the final CSS
in every lesson so that's there for your
reference as long as you keep in mind
the the pre pending final double
underscore now let's jump into our
sandbox CSS so what we're gonna do here
is start coding up our style so let's
the first thing we're gonna do is code
up that overlay and we're simply going
to say position fixed top zero and left
right and bottom are all going to be 0
that just tells the position fixed
element that it's going to be connected
to all four sides because a fixed
position kind of jumps it up to the top
top left so you need to position it
specifically so it knows to stretch
itself is that index 99 that's just
going to put it in front of everything
on the page for the most part background
we're gonna say I'm gonna go double
triple zero thought black pointer events
this specific selector specifies it says
right here right on the on the code
editor specifies under what
circumstances if any a particular
graphic element can become the target of
Mouse events so our overlay we don't
actually want it to be the target of a
mouse event so we want to be able to
click through it we don't want it to to
conflict with if we want to click
something so the the overlay you can
sorry the pointer events you can have
set to auto or none or any number of
different events in fact if you just
check here in Mozilla org for the
developer page you can see the syntax of
pointer events basically if you choose
auto the element behaves as if if the
pointer events property were not
specified at all so just default and
none the element is never the target of
Mouse events that simply means if you
click it it shouldn't register as
anything so and we're just doing
for just to prevent any issues with
clicking the overlay being on top of
different things it's very likely we
could not have the pointer events style
in there at all and it would be fine on
some browsers but we have that in there
specifically to to avoid any conflict
with click events so pointer events none
for the overlay because we don't want to
be able to have it register as a click
event when we click on it opacity 0 we
don't wanna see it
WebKit transform we're going to scale it
we're gonna make it half the size so
that scale is 0.5 we're gonna put this
as transform as a browser cross
compatibility scale 0.5 so it's half the
size right now but you can't see it
because it's opacity is 0 now let's move
along we're gonna style the input with
the type of checkbox so our magical
check box but the checked state of it so
that check box with the check State this
is the style that we're going to do but
we're gonna use a general sibling
Combinator this little character means
any sibling of this element so not
necessarily just the adjacent sibling so
if there is an input and then right
below it
that's an adjacent sibling as long as
they are siblings in fact it could be
any sibling that I specify within the
document tree not necessarily an
adjacent one so we're gonna select
overlay so basically one just when the
input is checked I'm actually gonna be
selecting the overlay sibling pointer
events Auto for this opacity let's do
0.9 I'm gonna go WebKit transform scale
that to 1 and I'm going to do that again
here for cross compatibility on the
browsers and then what we're going to do
is WebKit's transition we're going to to
transition the transform at 0.5 seconds
and ease I'm going to transition the
opacity at 0.5 seconds with a nice copy
that paste it out remove WebKit simply
from cross-compiled cross browser
compatibility that should do that okay
so let's save that and see what happens
if i refresh and i click on click to
launch modal we have our overlay slides
up nice and just like so but I can't
remove it because there's no way for me
to remove it and that's something that
we are actually going to start to do
here so below that we're actually going
to style the modal and we're gonna say
position fixed top 50% left
50% zette index 100 we're gonna do some
WebKit transform here we're gonna
translate which is the X and y position
on the screen negative 15 negative 50
and then scale 0.5 so half the size now
if I save that let's see what it looks
like so far so you can see it here it's
50% of the size and it's negative 50%
negative 80 percent if I were to change
this to 50% and 50% let's see what
happens it's somewhere down here so the
negative 15 negative 50 is the is the
position of it so it's actually right
dead center as you could see but it's
half the size we're gonna scale it up
once it's activated copy that paste it
remove WebKit there we go we're gonna go
here and we're gonna say width and we're
gonna do 100% and Max which 640 so it's
basically always 600 and a maximum of
640 but under that it will be 100%
basically responsive styles pointer
events none and opacity 0 beautiful now
I'm going to do is style the modal when
the input is checked so now it's hidden
you can't see it so now let's do
something when you can see it type of
checkbox the checked state the general
sibling Combinator but we're gonna style
the modal this time pointer events Auto
opacity one we're gonna do WebKit
transform and we're going to say
translate we're going to position that
it's going to be the same as this so I'm
just going to
copy that and paste it out but the scale
is gonna be one we want that to actually
grow to its full size so it doesn't look
silly and now we're going to do some
transitions we're gonna transform 0.5
seconds ease and the opacity at 0.5
seconds and ease copy that sorry no I
don't need to copy that
yes I do for the WebKit there we go that
looks good so the transition will will
transition the transform and the opacity
so that means that those specific things
will animate if I didn't specify that it
would not affect it would not animate to
the transform or it would not animate
the opacity you can actually animate the
position and other elements as well
other states and now we're going to do a
transition delay 0.1 seconds and that's
just going to wait 0.1 seconds before it
animates just to give it like a little
bit of a cascading effect and one last
thing we're going to just style up the
modal double underscore content and
we're going to say display block we're
going to give it some padding of 30
pixels and a background of white or a
triple F save that check it out in the
browser refresh click on your click to
launch modal there it is it opens up the
modal is there at the close button if we
click it closes everything back out
check this out when I click it watch
that the overlay comes first and then in
1.1 seconds later the modal pops up so
it's very subtle but check it out it
just has a nice
you
creepy that was very good thank you for
hanging out with me on number 16 day
number 16 modal window I hope you
enjoyed it hope this gave you a few
ideas to use on your own websites and
applications perhaps build some CSS only
modal windows in your own projects it's
a very functional thing it's something
that you can use it's cross browser
compatible it's just CSS so it should
work everywhere for the most part so
enjoy have a good day of seeing tomorrow
in day number 17
[Music]